[Musik]
wieso
plapperst du kehrt die Bitte um heute
morgen
[Musik]
wenn ich dich so nehme so eigentlich ist
sie mit Herz blutlehrerin es ist ihr
Traumberuf Sand arbeitet seit über 20
Jahren als Primarlehrerin doch bei
dieser Klasse kommt sie an ihre Grenzen
[Musik]
an einer Schule im kleinen Basel wollen
wir Lehrkräfte Einblick geben in den
modernen Schulalltag während Wochen
begleite ich sie mit meiner Kamera und
erlebe ihren Alltag voller
Herausforderungen
2011 gibt es einen Systemwechsel in der
Schweizer Volksschule
Kleinklassen Sonderschulen und
Spezialangebote gehören der
Vergangenheit an
möglichst alle Kinder sollen eine
Regelschule besuchen also integriert
werden
Basel Stadt nimmt eine Vorreiterrolle
ein beim sogenannten integrativen
Schulmodell
in der zweiten Klasse von Sandra matt
gibt es große Unterschiede zwischen den
primarschülerinnen und Primarschüler
innen
die Schule fördert die Kinder in
verschiedenen Sonderprogrammen
etwa Heilpädagogik Logopädie
Psychomotorik oder hier orange die
begabten Förderung aktuell hat nur ein
Kind keinen Sonderprogramm laut der
Lehrerin erhält die Klasse und 7
Zusatzstunden gesprochen weitere
Maßnahmen haben der Kanton abgelehnt
oder die Eltern der Kinder sein dagegen
es ist sehr breite
ich kann mich nicht teile ich würde gern
für jedes Kind die unterschiedlich
machbar weil es sind acht Sachen Kinder
oder so sieht man wie viel mehr
Brüste Unterstützung
und das kann ich nicht leisten
inzwischen ist der Hilferuf ganz oben
angekommen im Erziehungsdepartement des
Kantons
wenn man am Schulsysteme
doch Lehrerin mad kann nicht mehr warten
bereits im vergangenen Schuljahr
informiert Sie die Schulleitung über die
Schwierigkeiten
so nein mache ich das nicht
und jetzt buche ich Unterstützung
[Musik]
die Primarschulen Thomas Platten und
Wettstein liegen im kleinen Basel
einst ein Arbeiter und
einwandererviertel auf der rechten Seite
des Rheins
heute ist es vor allem ein Ort der
Gegensätze ein besonders
multikultureller Stadtteil
Kinder von wohlhabenden Akademikern
Kinder von Flüchtlingen und der
Nachwuchs gutbürgerlicher Familien sie
alle treffen sich im selben Schulhaus
2022 hat die Lehrerschaft beim
Bildungsdepartement des Kantons Basel
Stadt eine Initiative für Förderklassen
eingereicht die Verhandlungen sind im
Gange
[Musik]
Sandra Merch holt ihre Klasse vom
Pausenplatz ab eine Maßnahme weil die
Konflikte im Gang regelmäßig eskalieren
[Musik]
in der Schule das weißt du ganz genau
[Applaus]
die Schulleitung nimmt Sandra metris
Hilfe Ruf Ernst sie stellt ihr Paula
Pfau zur Seite die gerade den Abschluss
ihrer pädagogischen Ausbildung macht ich
freue mich auf Kinder
jetzt bin ich ganz gespannt was sehr
die zwei Frauen führen die Klasse nun zu
zweit
nicht alle Kinder möchten gefilmt werden
ein Praktikant hilft zusätzlich mit
in der 2b gibt es ein Begrüßungsritual
gemacht
[Musik]
die Kinder wollen zwischen Tänzchen
Umarmung oder abklatschen
im Schwimmbad ja hier tut es weh aber du
hast ein schönes Sommerfarbe
Montagmorgen Paula Pfau kontrolliert als
erstes die Hausaufgaben der achtjährigen
dabei geht es nicht nur um Schulbildung
sondern auch darum ob die Kinder zum
Beispiel genügend frühstücken was ist
denn da passiert ich habe es einmal
Duschen dann hat er bezahlt musst du
deine Sachen beschützt okay
[Musik]
vorbereitet
Kinder
organisieren und wenn du jetzt Sachen
machen wenn du das machst
Organisation
jedes Kind arbeitet mit persönlichem
Ziel und Programm
also beim ersten Mal doch konzentrieren
können sich längst nicht alle
[Musik]
das Foto
wieso kreativ
ja ich komme zu dir
alle Arbeiten dort wo es Ihnen am besten
passt
draußen im Gang ziehen sich zwei
leistungsstarke Kinder zurück auf der
Suche nach Ruhe
[Musik]
die Personen stehen ja da schon okay
im gleichen Primarschulhaus unterrichtet
Markus harzenmoser
[Applaus]
er steht kurz vor der Pensionierung nach
39 Jahren mit seiner aktuellen Klasse
laufe es gut doch auch er hat sorgen es
geht mehr Kinder wo kein Frosch Toleranz
viel abnimmt daheim und sie dann wenn
sie dort bis mir
ausstellenbarkeit und Unselbständigkeit
dir dann gegeben stimmt
hast du rausgefunden was was eigentlich
nicht gestimmt hat
der stimmt immer noch nicht
warten Mose hat sich einen Namen gemacht
weil er sich für kleinere Klassen für
schwierige Kinder einsetzt sogenannte
Förderklassen
er will die Bedingungen für die künftige
Lehrer Generation verbessern in den
nächsten acht Jahren fehlen schweizweit
gemäss Prognose rund 11.000 Lehrkräfte
auf Primarstufe Kolleginnen
sind und den finde ich gehört auch zum
Job dass ich dann mehr für diese also
das andere integrierte
aber die psychisch ich sage immer
vernarbte Kinder
und sobald das funktioniert problemlos
nimmt die Tinte darf ich Sie bei dir
vorbei schicken zum erklären wie du das
gelöst hast und das kannst du noch dem
Luis bringen der hat das nämlich
vergessen
trotz seiner Erfahrung ist doch eher
immer wieder gefordert ein Kind flippt
aus
Frauen
irgendwas Schönes oder die Situation die
die so nervt
was ich jetzt später schon wieder
Problem
das ist halt schwierig ist dass es immer
mehr Kinder gibt von den belagstraße
älteren
und mehr und
Kollegium oder auswendig wird
die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer unterstützen
sich gegenseitig der Berufsalltag ist
oft ein Ausprobieren von neuen Ideen
beispielsweise startet eine Schülerin
von Sandra med mit einer Meditation in
den Tag
sie geht dafür in eine andere Klasse
[Musik]
du spürst deinen Körper auf der ruhiges
deine Füße deine Hände
du gehst zurück zu deinem Atem und du
bist nicht wütend oder enttäuscht
es ist normal die Gedanken tragen dich
weg und du kommst zurück
noch einmal den Atem spüren
[Musik]
behalte dir öffne die Augen
dann gehst du an deinen normalen Platz
und legst dein Mäppchen auf den Tisch
beweg mich im Kreis und mache alle
Kinder und ruhig dann und das mache ich
mich ein bisschen
müde
dass sie Konzentration lernen
und das ist ein bisschen
alles um Ruhe in ihr Klassenzimmer zu
bringen
sie können
schnurrenidee
ich brauche viele Freunde ich habe nicht
so viel hätte sie Zeit dass man wir
versucht sie halt durchaus dass sie da
sitzt im
Sozialrecht es kommt nicht zum schaffen
dass sie wieder die Möglichkeit hat wo
sie sich konzentrieren
das Holz Bedürfnis vom vom ruhigen
schaffe oder für sich keine schaffe du
ihn nicht
geistig und
verzögert das alle einigermaßen kann
damit Kinder einigermaßen Platz haben
man muss Gefühl haben sie können
einigermaßen ruhig schaffen und den
haben wir die
Sichtschutzwände gebaut
ja das ist und sie sagt es auch sie
wünschen sich das auch sie sagen
eigentlich
Aufwand habe stark zugenommen Sitzungen
außerhalb der Schule Gespräche
Koordination der Fördermaßnahmen und die
Elternarbeit belasten die Lehrerinnen
schickt jedes Kind in seine individuelle
Fördermaßnahme
ich komme gerade wieder zurück ich muss
schnell die anderen in Logopädie
schicken
wir jetzt zurück von der Logopädie um
ihn in Psychomotorik und da wo sonst im
Urlaub
die andere
sie sind da jetzt muss ich schnell die
zwei Kinder holen wo im Logopädie gehen
die sind am Mittwoch in der Bibliothek
da gibt es etwa die Logopädie die
Begabtenförderung die Heilpädagogik oder
wie hier die Psychomotorik
er
wir treffen uns auf der Bank wie gewohnt
jetzt geht es so du darfst ein Auto
aussuchen
und das Auto fährt einmal über deinen
Körper
z.B fährt es dort an der Hand
hochfährt über deine Schultern
und dort wieder raus jetzt zeige ich dir
meine Autogarage schau mal welches Auto
findest du gut
was du wartest du wartest
oha
was ist das Lamborghini
frauenkuchen und das Auto kommt wenn er
jetzt ist gut wenn du ganz leise bist
weil Vanessa muss gut spüren wo das Auto
fährt okay ich mache die erste Runde in
der zweiten können wir abwechseln das
Auto kommt
es ist eine Übung zu Körperwahrnehmung
und wie schön die Aufmerksamkeit auf den
Körper das heißt Kinder werden trainiert
den Fokus zu halten und sich ganz
gezielt auf einen Punkt zu konzentrieren
und damit stärken wir auch die
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne in dem Moment wo
wir es wieder aufs Papier bringen das
heißt vom Körper in den Kopf sozusagen
schulen wir diese Verbindung zwischen
Körper und Geist und das ist eigentlich
das was die Psychomotorik ausmacht
schaut welches Auto willst
dann darfst Du Dich ganz platt legen die
Arme so dass ich die Arme auch befahren
kann sehr gut
Klassenausflug in den Wald Paula Pfauen
eine Woche in der Natur verbringen von
dieser Maßnahme erhoffen sie sich einen
positiven Einfluss auf die Kinder
[Gelächter]
oder will einige Kinder in der Klasse
positiv
der Wald als Ort ohne Display und ohne
Reizüberflutung
[Musik]
oh nein über Nacht haben Unbekannte den
selbstgebauten Märchenwald der Kinder
zerstört ich verstehe es ich wäre jetzt
auch traurig sogar vielleicht ein
bisschen wie dünnt oder enttäuscht
und jetzt machen wir so
ihr habt jetzt mal freies Spiel
und dann könnt ihr vielleicht kommt ihr
beim Spielen noch eine gute Idee wer
weiß viel Spaß
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie geht es mit den anderen
[Musik]
wir können mal hinten Kamera zeigen
nach dem austoben zeigt sich ein ganz
anderes Bild als im Klassenzimmer
es ist Anja
Unmöglichkeit ist
ein neuer Tag
die Situation im Schulhaus bleibt
angespannt das lederkollegium versucht
sich weiterhin zu unterstützen wo es
geht
viertklässlehrerin Corinna Büsch geht es
gleich wie Sandra Mädchen
[Musik]
einfach
Probleme intensiver
wenn wo scheinbar einfach immer mehr
präsent wird sie und ich
einige Tage später kontaktiert mich
Corina Büsch sie wollen mir die
unerträglichen Zustände in ihrer Klasse
zeigen
und tatsächlich wurde kurz darauf in
Lehrerin Böschs Klassenzimmer randaliert
an der Wandtafel Wüste Beleidigungen
zugleich ist heute der Geburtstag von
Corinna Büsch
[Musik]
die Kinder finden sich zwischen
Geburtstagsüberraschung und beschmierte
Wandtafel wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
parallelklassenlehrerin Corinna Weber
organisiert die Überraschungsparty
ja es
ist schockieren
den Ereignisse die Überraschung wird
nicht abgesagt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eigentlich wollte ich ja unterrichten
aber das geht jetzt gerade nicht so gut
ja
es waren Sachen rumgeschmissen worden es
wurde in meine Sachen gespuckt es wurden
Sachen rumgeworfen es war total
chaotisch gruselig und ganz schlimme
Sachen die an der Wandtafel standen und
ich will jetzt hat muss rausfinden was
da passiert ist
jetzt träumen wir ein bisschen auf so
dass wir Unterricht machen können und
ähm ja in der Klassenstunde können wir
auch noch Sachen die anstehen besprechen
weil wir sollten jetzt eigentlich machen
oder das war jetzt ein bisschen
für die Lehrerin ist der Vorfall auch
ein Ausdruck der Überforderung
also das ist jetzt nicht aber ich finde
das
böse Kinder
[Musik]
zehn elfjährige also
das oder nicht
aber das ist wirklich extrem
betont sie wie gerne sie ihr Lehrerin
ist und bleibt und wie sie eigentlich
ein gutes Verhältnis zur Klasse habe das
integrative Schulsystem für sie eine
Knacknuss bei dem es noch einiges zu tun
gibt
dessen ist sich auch Regierungsrat
Conrad in Kramer bewusst er betont dass
man Maßnahmen eingeleitet habe wird zwar
Lerninseln oder Fördergruppen der Kanton
will an der Integration festhalten und
dennoch wieder mehr separieren
damit ein integrative
[Musik]
Möglichkeiten wichtig ist vor allem dass
es auch erwähnt zurückgeht aus der
Separation wieder in der Regel Klasse
man dürfen nicht weg zu machen für die
Kinder das ist ganz entscheidender
Faktor
für das neue Schuljahr 2024 wurde das
Pensum von Paula Paul erhöht ihre
Kollegen genau darin die Lösung das bei
einer solchen Klasse die Lehrkräfte
Doppel besetzt sind nach wie vor sind
immer motiviert probieren noch Lust
auf andere Klasse Lehrpersonen und suche
jetzt einfach wie man am besten mit
allen 18 Kinder keine vorwärts kommen
alle Beteiligten wollen nur das Beste
für die Kinder nur wie das ist die große
Frage
[Musik]